if you want a film that sums up all the
forget ability about Disney I probably
pointed the Aristocats I've only seen
this movie once or twice in my life and
every time I have I totally forgotten
that I even watched it again like most
Disney movies there's nothing really
that terrible about it I just can't find
anything really spectacular about it
or even that good Disney movies like
this really annoy me though because it's
just being cutesy for the sake of being
cutesy okay what's the story this Butler
finds that he's gonna inherit a bunch of
cats and it turns out he hates cats he's
allergic to online can't stand them so
he tries to get rid of them through the
old-fashioned cliche of throwing them
off a bridge which by the way my the
only one disturbed that that's an
old-fashioned cliche do people actually
do this what's wrong with folks back
then anyway there are these two pretty
funny dogs that chase them down and we
do get a pretty entertaining chasing out
of it but after that it's just the cats
trying to find their way home and the
other interesting cats that they come
across along the way there's no depth
there's no intrigue there's no
interesting twists and turns there's no
Bond adventure
it's just cats looking cute and bouncing
around to fun music I don't know even as
a kid I remember being really bored by
this movie I hear other people liked it
when they were younger but I don't know
many that liked it now that they're
older I actually find it one of the
weaker Disney film simply because it
leaves little to no impact even Disney
when it made its biggest mistakes at
least two left memorable mistakes this
one I never even have any memory of
watching yeah I'm probably being too
harsh on it it probably was meant for
much much younger kids but from Disney I
expected a lot more better story better
characters better animation personally
I'd skip